ehi ciao
[Musica]
il nostro mondo si è ristretto negli
ultimi decenni
stiamo assistendo ad un grande
cambiamento antropologico del mondo in
cui viviamo per le nostre città per le
vie del mondo non incontriamo più
viaggiatori come il signor fox e il suo
fedele passepartout per chi ha letto il
romanzo di jules verne il giro del mondo
in 80 giorni la velocità con cui si sta
muovendo la nostra società il mondo in
rete ha trasformato tutti noi in
viaggiatori virtuali in giro per il
mondo ma senza uscire da una stanza
anche la geografia del mondo sta
cambiando e le nuove tecnologie ci
consegnano ci hanno trasformato ormai in
questi viaggiatori virtuali senza
biglietto senza valigia però troppo
spesso anche senza una meta
e un percorso mi chiama roberto
malinconico sono uno psicologo
psicoterapeuta lavoro nel settore delle
dipendenze
sostengo le attività di un'associazione
l'associazione melagrana che da
vent'anni è impegnata nella promozione
della pace e del contrasto di tutte le
forme di povertà della persona umana la
mia attività professionale ma anche il
mio impegno civile mi ha portato in giro
per il mondo a contatto con realtà
difficili in realtà dove la precarietà
dell'esistenza e la quotidianità per
milioni e milioni di persone che vivono
esclusi e ai margini di un mondo che non
li vuole li lascia li lascia ultimi
questa esperienza mi ha portato anche a
delle riflessioni che in un modo o
nell'altro
sento di poter condividere con tutti voi
la società liquida che ha iniziato il
nuovo millennio è praticamente evaporata
evaporata nelle mille strade della
società virtuale noi siamo passati nel
volgere di un secolo dalla società
solida alla società liquida alla società
virtuale
la società liquida di cui parlava bauman
era quella società che praticamente
vedeva il volgere di un salto
generazionale nel giro di pochissimo 35
anni che non dava tempo di consolidare
l'esperienza del vivere del presente una
società dove l'incerto era l'unica cosa
certa dove la precarietà dell'esistenza
e anche delle relazioni si poneva a
ciascuno di noi alla ricerca costante di
che cosa del consumismo del bene
effimera d'avere dell'apparire a tutti i
costi l'apparire che diventa valore
noi avevamo una società solida che
vedeva un salto generazionale che quel
cambio di passo in un in un tempo e in
un periodo storico in cui cambiano le
mode cambiano i costumi gli stili di
vita che avveniva in 20 30 anni e siamo
passati poi addirittura alla società
virtuale dove è difficile definire un
salto generazionale tanto e veloce e
repentino il passaggio del tempo
noi spesso ci troviamo compriamo
addirittura un nei negozi questo lo
abbiamo tutti un cellulare contiamo
l'ultima novità dei in vetrina e usciamo
tutti contenti e già il commesso lo sta
sostituendo con il nuovo prodotto più
nuovo innovativo rispetto a quello che
abbiamo comprato
ma già la fabbrica che l'ha prodotto sta
producendo il nuovo prodotto il nuovo
cellulare
i progettisti stanno consegnando alla
lavorazione
il nuovo modello che sarà prodotto noi
siamo tutti contenti siamo usciti con il
nuovo ultimo modello che è vecchio di
quattro generazioni
e ovvio che tutto questo nella
tecnologia ma pensate nelle relazioni ci
porta praticamente ad una modernità che
all'insegna della fragilità totale con
una precarietà un in sicurezza una
inadeguatezza del vivere la vita di
tutti i giorni
è questo praticamente ci mette in grande
difficoltà
l'obsolescenza precoce è un concetto che
è stato coniato proprio per dare il
senso di questa velocità questa velocità
che in un modo o nell'altro sta
caratterizzando il nostro tempo è uno
stimolo
sembra strano avere un obsolescenza che
ha un termine coniato dalla sociologia
industriale per dire che i sistemi di
produzione non erano più adeguati alle
nuove produzioni quelle più innovative e
la società virtuale praticamente si
trova in una condizione nella quale non
ce la fa
con questo termine a spiegare quanto ci
muoviamo velocemente e viviamo un tempo
in cui abbiamo obsolescenza precoce non
riusciamo a vivere il presente ma lo
stesso eraclito circa duemila anni più
di duemila di fascia spiegato che non
era possibile bagnarsi nella stessa
acqua di un fiume due volte ovvero non è
possibile vivere due volte lo stesso
tempo lo stesso momento
guardate il presente a un verbo che lo
accompagna che è il verbo e spedire
noi il presente non lo possiamo
ragionare perché se lo ragioniamo e
passato non lo possiamo vedere perché è
nella dimensione futura non esiste deve
ancora arrivare
il presente lo possiamo solo vivere in
una società che si muove così
velocemente tanto da non consentire la
maturazione delle esperienze che succede
succede che abbiamo un passato un
presente e un futuro senza soluzione di
continuità che si susseguono così
velocemente tanto da schiacciarci da non
consentirci in nessun modo di vivere
esperienze e relazioni
lo dicevamo per quanto riguarda gli
aspetti scientifici immaginate sul piano
relazionale quello che succede tra le
persone perché il non riuscire a
consolidare esperienze nel presente
significa anche non riuscire a maturare
relazioni a vivere una dimensione
dell'altro in termini relazionali
comunicativi affettivi noi abbiamo
quindi una situazione in cui il passato
non riesce a diventare memoria il
presente non riusciamo a viverlo e il
futuro praticamente rubato e questo non
è poco perché il futuro noi lo
costruiamo anche attraverso la
possibilità di vivere il presente
attraverso la possibilità di vivere
giorno dopo giorno un po come quel gioco
che fanno i bambini che si trovano a
vivere una condizione nella quale si
proiettano in un mondo adulto si vivono
come
astronauti i camionisti esploratori poi
lo saranno non lo saranno non è
importante però intanto in questa
dimensione a noetica loro costruiscono
il loro futuro
ebbene una condizione di assenza del
presente
ci porta ad avere una perdita della
nostra capacità di previsione futura
c'è una crisi noetica in cui le persone
la società fa fatica ad incontrarsi la
perdita del presente quindi determina
fragilità in ciascuno di noi
le nuove generazioni sono quelle che più
di tutti vivono questo dramma in una
società che ci vuole sempre più soli e
in solitudine che ci vuole sempre più in
isolamento l'uno rispetto agli altri ma
anche in una condizione di aggressività
crescente degli uni verso gli altri
perché perdere il presente significa non
avere più occasioni per rivivere
esperienze ne abbiamo una e dobbiamo
afferrare al volo anche se poi tanti
altri restano indietro abbiamo una
società che si muove troppo velocemente
e troppa gente e troppe persone restano
ultimi all'interno di questo percorso
certo la società virtuale in questo
cambiamento antropologico a dei suoi
aspetti positivi lo sa
all'interno della delle nuove scoperte
della nuova tecnologia lo all'interno
delle comunicazioni avendo ampliato il
raggio e la possibilità di poter
raggiungere tante parti del mondo che
prima non erano raggiungibili ha quindi
ammesso in collegamento il il mondo
stesso ma presente elementi di grande
criticità lo abbiamo detto il primo di
tutti all'interno della relazione della
relazione proprio tra le persone la
solitudine ma anche la l'isolamento in
cui intere classi di persone soprattutto
le nuove generazioni vivono la mia
attività professionale mi ha portato
spesso a lavorare nelle scuole e a
parlare con gli studenti a volte mi
capita di fare un gioco con loro
nell'aula magna chiamo i due ragazzi le
due ragazze che sono agli estremi
dell'aula magna l'invito a venire a
raggiungermi a mettersi l'uno di fronte
all'altro ea narrarsi a raccontarsi
l'uno rispetto all'altro e scoprire con
grande meraviglia soprattutto da parte
loro che si sentono e sono estranei e
magari sono da 34 anni all'interno dello
stesso istituto senza conoscersi e
quindi questo determina una condizione
che ci deve far riflettere un po tutti
quanti ci deve far riflettere perché
viviamo in una società quella virtuale
che ha ci vuole sempre più competitivi
l'uno verso l'altro abbandonando l'idea
invece di una società che può essere
cooperativa dove gli uni e gli altri
possono in un modo o nell'altro fare
fare insieme ragionare insieme io credo
che abbiamo una sfida importante che ci
attende un compito importante se
vogliamo determinare anche un
cambiamento in questa tendenza per
rallentare questa velocità di
trasformazione della nostra società e
che riprendere un'educazione alla
relazionalità per aiutare regione
relazione generazione a riconoscersi
se non conoscessi di nuovo
e credo che questo sia importante non
voglio essere chi può passare per
luddista contro perché ce l'ha con la
tecnologia che cela contro il progresso
io credo che noi dobbiamo rallentare
rallentare non vuol dire regredire
significa semplicemente fare in modo che
il progresso possa essere declinato con
i tempi delle relazioni delle persone
l'una in relazione con l'altro nel mio
girare spesso mi sono trovato in realtà
con le quali l'ho detto
gli ultimi sono stati maestri direzione
di grande generosità davanti ai tanti
che cercavano stati individuali
solitarie gli ultimi quelli che sono io
definisco i portatori di sconfitte erano
quelli che invece si davano più da fare
in lezione di generosità verso gli altri
a me viene in una scena bellissima che è
di un sono le pagine finale quasi come
un dipinto di un romanzo che di john
steinbeck furore le pagine finali
parlano di una di una donna una
partoriente che aveva appena partorito
purtroppo morto il suo bambino che aveva
il seno al rondò di latte e che vede una
via terra in una stanza una un uomo che
sta morendo di di nebbia di stenti
perché non mangiava da giorni e giorni
ebbene quasi come in un dipinto questa
donna nel dramma della sua disperazione
nel dramma dell'estrema povertà lo
prende tra le braccia lo porta al seno
per sfamarlo ebbene questa scena che io
credo che sia la l'esempio forte di
quello che dicevo della generosità degli
ultimi dei portatori di sconfitte
credo sia
degli esempi importanti per rovesciare
questo paradigma diventate da portatori
di sconfitta a portatori di nuova
umanità una nuova umanità che sia fatta
però di persona che sia fatta di storia
e si è fatto di racconti che possono
diventare memoria quella memoria che la
società virtuale non ci consente di
mettere insieme di solidificare perché
ci annulla ci ruba le esperienze non ci
fa costruire il futuro
i portatori di nuovo ma netta fatta di
sogni di sogni che tracciano la strada
per il futuro che deve essere per donne
e uomini ovunque in questo mondo grazie
per aver condiviso con me queste
riflessioni
[Applauso]
[Musica]